Transcriber: Melis Kıral
Gözden geçirme: Ozay Ozaydin
Çok kalabalıkmış.
Ben vazgeçebiliyor muyum?
Yok mu artık, peki, hoş geldiniz.
Evrende yalnız mıyız?
Aslında basit ama çok ilginç bir soru.
Çünkü Türkiye’de bile, ben siyasetle
ilgilenmiyorum falan diyen var
ama bu soruyla, ben ilgilenmeyen
hiç kimse görmedim.
Yani hakikaten de var oluşumuz ile alakalı
öyle bir yere temas ediyor olmalı ki
bu sadece astrobiyolojinin, astronominin
ya da bilim kurgunun konusu değil.
Baya baya,
yani, toplumun her kesiminden entelektüel
bir alan da değil demek.
Herkes “Acaba uzaylılar var mı?”
sorusunun cevabı ile ilgilenir.
Yani, bu boş verip
geçebileceğiniz bir soru değil.
Bir çocukken bu sorunun cazibesine
çok kapıldım.
Ama biz çocukken kaynaklar; Mustafa
Topaloğlu, Sadettin Teksoy
bu gibi şeylerle sınırlıydı.
Benimle aynı yoldan geçen herkes
Erich von Däniken’in
“Tanrıların Arabaları“nı okumuş.
Yani bir zihin kirlenmesine maruz kalmadan
bu soruyla baş etmek
pek de mümkün değildi.
Ben çocukken hep gökyüzüne bakardım.
Herkesin kabusları cinler, periler iken;
benimki “Ya balkonumuzda
bir uzaylı belirirse?” idi.
Veyahut ben hala 38 yaşındayım.
Kabuslarım gerçekten dünyanın istila
edilmesi üzerine.
Yani ben kabus görüyorsam
mutlaka dünya istila edilmiştir.
Korkuyor muyum hala bilmiyorum
ama bu soru çok büyük.
Çünkü bu sorunun yanıtı insanlıkla ilgili
her şeyi değiştirmeye muktedir.
Tabii kimileri zaten uzaylıların
geldiğine, dünyayı ziyaret ettiğine,
piramitleri inşa ettiğine,
vesaire inanıyor.
Ben ise hayır diyorum.
Bir bilimsel kuşkucu kimliğim dolayısıyla
bunu kategorik olarak reddediyormuşum
gibi algılanıyorum ama öyle değil.
Yani hakikaten de hani böyle bir şey
olduysa, buna en çok inanmak isteyen iki
kişiden biri benim, diğeri Carl Sagan’dı,
o rahmetli oldu, tek kaldım.
Yani gerçekten de buna inanmayı en çok
gönülden isteyenlerden birisiyim.
Ama maalesef bu kanıtlar güvenilir
değil ve çoğu da maalesef komik.
Yani bunu kabul etmeye çok hazır olan
insanlar var biliyorum ama maalesef
hiçbirisi güvenilir bir
kanıt teşkil etmiyor.
Şimdi birinci grup kanıtlar.
Genelde uçan daire fotoğrafları.
Uçan daire kelimesi bile aslında sonradan
tesadüf eseri ortaya çıkmış bir şey.
1947′de Kenneth Arnold isimli bir pilot,
katıldığı radyo programında gördüğü
ışıkların devinimini anlatmak için
suyun üzerinde seken
fincan tabakları gibiydi diyor.
Bu yanlış anlaşılıyor.
Yanlış anlaşıldığı için ertesi gün
manşetler; “Flying Saurcers” yani
uçan tabaklar, uçan daireler şeklinde
değişmeye başlıyor ve o tarih itibariyle
uzaylı tasvirleri de değişmeye başlıyor.
Halbuki o tarih öncesinde, tabii, insan
hayal gücü ancak ve ancak mevcut
teknolojiyle limitlenmiş olduğu için,
önce “Mysterious Airship”
yani gizemli hava gemileri
şeklinde tarif edilirken, 1900′ler
itibariyle biraz daha donanmanın da
ilerlemesiyle beraber bildiğimiz yüzen
gemilere benzemeye başlıyor.
Ve tabii ki o dönemin araba modası da
daha kare tasarım çizgilerine sahip.
Ve yine ekranda görmüş olduğunuz üzere,
araba modasını takip eden
bir uçan daire modası da mevcut.
Bu resimlerin çoğu maalesef sahte.
Yani elbette geçmişe giderek
bir şeyleri ispat edemeyiz.
Ama şunu biliyoruz ki bir uçan
daire fotoğrafı yapmak
çok da büyük uzmanlık gerektirmiyor.
Çoğu da bunların endüstriyel mutfak
aletleri, yani uçan tabaklar olduğu için
oradan da ilhamla beraber ya da
sonradan ben de fark ettim,
duş başlığı çok popüler.
Örneğin bugün de siz duş başlığını
kullanarak, çok rahat bir şekilde,
çok gerçekçi,
geçmiştekilerden çok daha gerçekçi
uçan daire fotoğrafları yapabilirsiniz.
Bu fotoğraflarla ilgili
şöyle bir problem de var.
Bunlar 60'larda, 70'lerde
inanılmaz popülerdi.
Yani her ay gazetelerde işte bilmem nerede
uçan daire gözlendi gibi
fotoğraf ve tanıklıklara
rastlayabiliyoruz.
Ama bugün yok.
Bu bir paradoks oluşturuyor.
Çünkü bu sahnede bakıyorum,
eminim ki herkesin şu an cebinde bilmem
kaç megapiksel kalitesinde, hatta bilmem
kaç defa zoom özelliğine sahip fotoğraf
makinesi vardır.
Olmayan olduğunu hiç sanmıyorum.
Hepimiz cebimizde artık fotoğraf
makinasıyla geziyoruz.
Eğer ki 60′lardaki, 70′lerdeki
fotoğraf makinesi sayısıyla
uçan daire fotoğrafı oranını,
bugüne sabit tutup getirmeye kalksak;
sosyal medyaya şu an her bir saatte
bir uçan daire fotoğrafı
düşmesi gerekiyor.
O zaman buradan tek bir soru çıkıyor.
Uzaylılar bizden gizlenmeyi
iyi öğrenmişler.
Ya da bu fotoğrafların hepsi zaten
sahte idi ve bu furya sona erdi.
Ama sizinle en gerçekçi bulduğum
fotoğrafı paylaşmak istiyorum.
Finlandiya’da bir vatandaş bu fotoğrafı
çekmiş, ismine de Mini UFO demiş .
Eve gidip tab ettiğinde aslında kendisi
hayal kırıklığına uğramış olmalı
fakat bana göre en gerçekçisi bu.
Niçin derseniz, çünkü
uzaylıların yörüngeye geldikten sonra
dünyaya içerisinde, 7-8 mürettebat koyup
bir gemi göndermesinden daha
mantıklısı, dron göndermeleri.
Tabii dron bugün var.
Biz bunun varlığını biliyoruz ama 70'lerde
böyle bir şeyin var olabileceği
hayal edilmediği için hiç kimse
uzaylıların dünya ziyaretini,
önden bir araç göndererek numune almak,
görüntü almak gibi kurgulamadı.
Kurgulamadığı için,
geçmişten kalan bu fotoğrafı ben
en gerçekçi olarak buluyorum.
Yani hakikaten bu fotoğraflar arasında
gerçek olma ihtimali olan bir tane
fotoğraf varsa bana göre o, budur.
İkinci grup kanıtlar ise;
kaçırılma vakaları.
Yine 60′larda,
70′lerde inanılmaz popüler.
Psikologlar, antropologlar bunun bir
zamanlar Meryem görme, Peygamber görme
kutsal varlık görme olaylarıyla benzerlik
gösterdiğini ve bunun da modern bir mit
olduğunu ortaya koyuyor.
Tabii bu kaçırılma vakaları bir
çift hariç hepsi erkek.
Ve kaçırılma nın sonu çiftleşme
ile bitiyor.
Yani bu mağdur olduğunu iddia eden
arkadaşlar, ben orada kendim için küçük,
insanlık için büyük bir adım attım
şeklinde gizli bir gururlanmaya sahipler.
İşte bu hikayelerin hepsi birbirine
benzerlik gösteriyor.
Yani kaçırılıyorlar.
Çeşitli tıbbi testlere
maruz bırakılıyorlar.
İşte en sonunda da uzaylı bir bireyle,
başka bir bireyle çiftleşiyorlar
melez çocuk oluşturmak için.
Bu anlatılarda bir problem var.
Tabii o zaman psikolog ve psikiyatrlar
bu işle çok ilgileniyorlar.
Hipnozdu, şuydu buydu...
Mesela kişilerden ameliyathane detaylarını
öğrenmek istiyorlar.
Görünen o ki uzaylılar yıldızları
aşıp geliyor.
Böyle adamı yatağından
şöyle ışıkla çekiveriyor
ve müthiş bir genetik teknolojisi var
melez varlık oluşturmak için.
Ama ameliyathane; Ankara Numune Hastanesi.
Çünkü adam daha fazlasını tarif
etmeyi beceremiyor.
Bu birinci problem.
Düşünsenize zaten,
sıra varmış falan işte.
Başka kaçırılmış varlıklarla
“Kardeşim sıraya gir!” falan.
İkinci problem de şu; adamı alıyorlar,
rızası dışında
biyolojik teste maruz bırakıyorlar.
Rızası dışında cinsel ilişkiye giriyorlar.
Adamı geri evine bırakıyorlar.
Şu inceliğe bakar mısınız?
Dünyada kalmadı böyle nazik
sapıklar değil mi yani?
Dünyadan 1 kişi eksilse
bizim için ne olacak?
Niyeyse uzaylılar onları geri bırakıyor.
Burada da bir tutarsızlık var.
Burada da bir çelişki var yani.
İkincisi de.
Şimdi uzaylı tasviri dediğimiz şey,
yani bu kişilerin bize anlattıkları
uzaylı tipi Hollywood’la uyuyor.
Şimdi Hollywood uzaylı tipini bize
benzetmek zorundaydı bütçe sebebiyle.
Yani siz bir uzaylı tasarlayacaksanız,
içine bir insanın girip oynaması lazım.
İçine bir insanın girip oynaması için,
onun insan boyutlarında olması lazım.
İki kolu iki bacağı
olması lazım bizim gibi,
bilateral simetriye sahip olması lazım.
Gözler, burun, ağız onlar da
aynı yerde olması lazım.
Dolayısıyla uzaylı tiplemesi Hollywood’un,
kaçınılmaz olarak bize benzer.
Oysa bu biyologların ya da evrimsel
biyologların bekleyeceği bir şey değildir.
Yani farklı bir gezegende ilerleyen yaşam,
farklı bir fenotip oluşturmak zorunda.
Farklı bir anatomi ile
sonlanması gerekiyor.
Ama bize benziyorlar.
Hatta burada o dönemin estetik
anlayışına da rastlarsınız.
Mesela uzaylılar iyiyse, ileri ise;
işte iri gözlü,
selvi boylu, mutlaka zayıf,
beyaz tenli,
işte burnu fındık, ağzı kahve fincanı...
Hani bir Türk annesi gelin mi
tarif ediyor, uzaylı mı tarif ediyorsunuz
çok birbirinden ayırt edilemiyor.
Yani resmen bu antroposantrik
bakış açısını uzaylılara yansıtıyoruz.
Hatta, şöyle bir durum var;
eğer uzaylılar kötüyse, aptalsa
direkt insan formundan çıkar,
insan olmaz zaten.
Eğer bir şekilde
hala humanoid bir forma sahipse,
O zaman da mutlaka tıknaz, şişman,
koca burunlu, koca kulaklı...
Bu Star Trek’te bile öyle.
Star Trek’e bile bakın, işte aptal ırklar,
kötücül ırkların
burunları kocamandı, kulakları kocamandı.
Yani yakışıklı olup da kötü
uzaylı olamıyorsunuz
ya da güzel olup kötü uzaylı olamazsınız.
Mutlaka bu bizim estetik anlayışımızla
bağlantılı olmalı.
Burada bir çelişki daha var.
O çelişki de şu;
siz bir kümesten kaçırdığınız tavukla
ne kadar iletişim kurabilirseniz,
bizi kaçıran uzaylıların, bizimle o kadar
iletişim kurabilmeleri lazım.
Yani bir şempanze ile oturup kuantum
fiziği tartışamıyorsunuz değil mi?
Şimdi buradaki uzaylılar çok ilginç.
Hani yıldızları aşacak kadar bir bilişsel,
zihinsel devrim yaşamışlar.
Çok ileriler, bizden kaçırdıkları ve
rızası dışında tecavüz ettikleri adama
mutlaka kendi gezegenleri anlatıyorlar.
Yani adam onlar için bir nesne ama
hani düşünsenize tavuğu kaçırıyorsunuz,
kesip yiyeceksiniz ama öncesinde
“Ya bak biz insanlar şöyle yaşıyoruz,
bunları yapıyoruz,
bu gibi şeylerden keyif alıyoruz
falan.” diye anlatıyorsunuz.
Bu çok beklendik bir şey değil.
İşte bu da zaten kaçıranların bilim kurgu
yazarı olmadığını ortaya koyuyor biraz.
Ben kaçırıldığımı iddia etsem,
herkesi daha ikna edebilecek,
tutarlı bir hikaye
yazabilirim diye düşünüyorum.
Tüm bunları anlatınca, işte o bilimsel
kuşkucu kimliğim nedeniyle
kategorik olarak reddettiğim düşünülüyor.
Ama öyle değil.
Yani benim ölmeden öğrenmez isem gözlerim
açık gider dediğim iki soru var:
Bir tanesi bu: “Evrende bizden başka,
zeki canlılar var mı?”
İkincisi, “Biz hakikaten de
zeki miyiz?” kısmı.
Yaş ilerledikçe geldi bu soru.
Bunun cevabından artık eminim.
Yaptığımız politik tercihlere ve gezegene
verdiğimiz zararı görünce,
onun cevabından eminim.
Ama birinci soru beni hala
çok heyecanlandırıyor.
O yüzden, bir de işin bilim tarafı var.
Bilim tarafı ne diyor?
Bilim tarafı iyimser.
İşte Drake denklemi.
Yine 60'ların bize hediyesi işte.
Galakside şu kadar yıldız varsa, işte bu
yıldızların şu kadarında yaşam gelişmişse,
bunların da şu kadarında radyo
iletişimi gelişmişse gibi.
Aslında evrene baktığımız zaman pek çok
yerde hayat görmemiz gerektiğiyle ilgili
bir varsayıma yol açıyor;
Drake denklemi.
Tabii o dönemlerde
Enrico Fermi de diyor ki;
“Ya madem evren bu kadar
yaşamla dolup taşıyor, neredeler?”
O zaman her yere bakınca, antenimizi
nereye çevirsek bir sinyal almamız lazım.
Ya da dünya; evren ortaya çıktıktan,
Büyük Patlama'dan 9 milyar yıl sonra
oluştu ve bu 9 milyar yıl içerisinde
galaksideki bir medeniyetin
her yeri fethetmesi,
çoktan bir yerlere
izini bırakması lazımdı.
Bunlar neredeler?
Bu iyimserlik aslında
ta bu radyo teknolojisinin
ve astronominin
ilk ilerlediği yıllardan geliyor.
O dönemde bir yerde yarışma yapıyorlar,
diğer gezegenlerle temas kurmak için.
İlk temas kurana
yüz bin frank verecekler.
Mars'ı kapsam dışı bırakıyorlar.
Orayla zaten herkes konuşur diye.
DÜşünün yani bu kadar bir iyimserlik.
Ama biz sondalar gönderdikçe,
uzayı dinledikçe bu iyimserlik de tabii
yavaş yavaş azalıp yerini
büyük sessizlik dediğimiz şeye bırakıyor.
Büyük sessizliğe önerilmiş
yüzlerce yanıt var.
Sadece Stefan Webb diye
bir yazar var mesela,
sadece Fermi paradoksu için
olası yanıtlara verilen yüz yanıtı
derlediği bir kitabı var.
Bunlar çok çeşitli.
İşte yıldızlar çok uzak ya da
biz onlarla iletişim kuramıyoruz
çünkü iletişim kurma yöntemleri farklı.
Yanlış yere bakıyoruz, yanlış veriye
bakıyoruz gibi yüzlerce yanıtı var.
Biz dedik ki neden yüz birinci olmasın?
Mehmet Emin Özer ile birlikte
yeni bir yanıt geliştirdik;
o da “aramayı bıraktılar”.
Bu aramayı bıraktılar yanıtımızı,
1965′te ortaya atılmış, bir telefonlu
dedikodu yayılma modeline uyarladık.
Yani “Uzaylılar muhtemelen dünyalılar mı?”
“Ah, onlar yok mu?” gibi.
Böyle bir şey değil tabii ki.
Bu model bize şunu söylüyor;
Mesela; diyelim siz bir bilgi öğrendiniz,
hemen telefonla arayıp
başkasına haber veriyorsunuz.
O başkası da öğreniyor.
Artık o da bir yayıcı hale geliyor.
Artık elimizde iki yayıcı var.
Bu iki yayıcımız da rastgele
birisini arıyor.
Onlara bu bilgiyi veriyorlar.
Artık onlar da yayıcı hale geliyor.
Etti dört yayıcı .
Ne zamana kadar?
Ta ki siz birini arayıp.
“Ya, işte böyle böyle bir şey olmuş.”
“Ben biliyorum ya onu,
sen yeni mi öğrendin?” derse;
siz diyorsunuz ki
“Tamam, bu yeteri kadar yayılmış.
Artık benim kimseye telefon
etmeme gerek yok.”
Ve siz artık bir suskun hale geliyorsunuz.
Şimdi bu modele göre 1965′te Delhi ve daha
sonrasında Candel, böyle bir durumda
insanların yüzde yirmi üçünün asla
bu bilgiden haberi olmadığını,
insanların yüzde yirmi üçünün
bunu duymadan
bu yayılma sürecinin
tamamlandığını ortaya koyuyor.
Şimdi hakikaten de öyle değil midir yani?
Türkiye’de bir şey olur
ama yine de sokak röportajlarında
onu hiç duymamış birilerine
rastlayabilirsiniz.
Ya da aynı şeyi sosyal medyada
siz yaparsınız.
Gündemde bir konu vardır, twit atarsınız,
birkaç twit atarsınız hatta,
sonra bakarsınız ki timeline’ınız
hep o twitlerle,
o konudaki twitlerle dolmuş.
Artık vazgeçersiniz, yazmazsınız.
Yani bunu yazmanın bir değeri yoktur.
Çünkü yeteri kadar yayılmıştır.
Şimdi biz dedik ki acaba
gelişmiş medeniyetler,
birbirleriyle bu iletişime girmiş,
hatta birbirlerine başkalarını arama,
başkalarını ziyaret etme teknolojisini
hediye etmiş
ama en nihayetinde hepsi suskun hale
gelmiş olabilir mi diye.
Bakın burada bir video var, bu videoda
görmüş olduğunuz gibi,
mesela burada şu an herkes suskun,
bir kişi o teknolojiye sahip.
Bu sarı çizgiler onun o teknolojiyi
ilettiği diğer medeniyetleri gösteriyor.
Fakat en nihayetinde herkes,
bilenler suskun hale geldikten sonra,
bir kısım medeniyetler
hala bu konudan habersiz kalıyor.
Tabii, biz bu şartları değiştirdik.
Mesela dedik ki, belki de tek bir
karşılaşmayla vazgeçmiyorlardır.
Ki olası.
Bazılarımız dedikoduyu daha çok sever.
On seferde mesela,
on sefere kadar çıkılsa,
veyahut bazen bir kişiye haberi
verdiğiniz zaman,
onu hemen yayıcı hale getirmeyebilirsiniz.
Herkes dedikoduyu sevmez.
Orada bir olasılık atadık.
Yani ben sizle haberi paylaştım.
Siz yüzde elli olasılıkla
siz bir yayıcı hale geliyorsunuz gibi.
Bu parametreler ışığında bunu
incelediğimiz zaman en iyi şartlarda bile,
bakın en iyi şartlarda bile, insan - insan
değil artık onlar, uzaylı dostlarımızın
binde ikisi bu teknolojiyi hiç almıyor,
ve bu temasa hiç katılmıyor.
Peki ya biz onlardan biri isek?
Bu size ikna edici gelmemiş olabilir.
Bir fotoğraf paylaşayım sizinle.
Bu fotoğraf, modern dünyayla hiç iletişim
kurmamayı başarmış,
hiç rast gelmediğimiz bir
Amazon kabilesini gösteriyor.
Biz bugün özel bir çaba sarf etmiyoruz.
Yani hiç haber almamış
olanları da bulalım,
onlarla da iletişim kuralım gibi
bir çaba sarf etmiyoruz.
Ve bütün modern dünyanın artık birbiriyle
iletişimde olduğunu varsayıyoruz.
Dolayısıyla belki hala bir yerlerde,
modern dünyayla hiç temas etmemiş
kabileler var.
İşte bizler, belki de post biyolojik
bir evredeyiz şu an dünya olarak.
Ve bu sebeple de hiç temas edilmedik
ve edilmeyeceğiz de.
Çünkü aramayı bıraktılar.
Ortaya en önemli soru çıkıyor.
Tamam, eğer var ve bizle temas
etmiyorlarsa bir şekilde ümitlenebiliriz
ki biz bir gün açılacağız.
Bizimle temas etmeyen bu
intergalaktik telefon kulübüne erişeceğiz.
Kendimiz yarışacağız ama ya yalnızsak?
Ya bizden başka canlı yoksa?
Bu bilim dışı bir ret gibi görünüyor
olabilir ama bunun sağlam temelleri var.
Dört buçuk milyar yıl önce dünyada
daha koşullar elverişli olur olmaz
yaşam fışkırmış gibi görünüyor.
Ama bu başka bir soruyu
beraberinde getiriyor.
Neden ikinci bir yaşam olmadı ?
Yani şöyle özetleyeyim.
Dünyadaki bütün canlılar aynı
kökenden geliyor ve akraba.
Yani hepimiz Seferoğullarıyız.
Tellioğulları nerede?
Hani neden dört milyar yıl önce dünyanın
başka bir noktasında DNA/RNA temelli
ya da bizimle aynı aminoasitlerle
değil ama başka aminoasitlerle
başka bir yaşam neden oluşmadı?
Madem bu kadar kolay,
o zaman belki de dünyadaki yaşam
hakikaten de kozmik bir
tesadüfün ürünüdür.
Yani şu Voyager-1′den çekilen ve
Carl Sagan’ın “soluk mavi nokta”
dediği fotoğraf orada.
Belki de bu ufacık gezegendeki yaşam
denilen şey, bütün evren ve kainatta
müstesna ve tek başına bir şeydir.
Bu çok enteresan bir şey.
Çünkü eğer böyleyse o tek başına bir şeyin
son halkası olan bizler,
hem bu dünyadaki diğer canlılara,
hem gezegenimize,
hem birbirimize zulmetmekte
çok mahiriz.
Yani burada çok kıymetli,
ender bir şey var.
Ama o ender şey, kendini ve o ender şeye
ev sahipliği yapan gezegenini yok etmekte,
ona acı çektirmekte hiç tereddüt etmiyor.
Bu çok saçma bir şey.
Peki ya yalnız değilsek?
Bu daha kötü .
Çünkü bu aptallığımıza şahit
olan birileri var demektir.
Teşekkürler.